hi will good to talk to you thanks for
joining us on the program this morning
um your reaction to the report
yeah morning kay um
look
honestly i feel pretty depressed this
morning it's a sad day i you know i'm
joining you from athens where i'm
working this morning i flew in last
night and i had breakfast an hour ago
overlooking the acropolis this is where
democracy was born and the uk
prides itself on exporting democracy
around the world but i just think it's a
bad day for democracy i think the detail
of this report is absolutely appalling
the partying people vomiting on the
walls you know there was even a fracar
some sort of fight at the height of
lockdown and this is at the heart of the
government of our country and i think
you know brutally speaking it it's a bit
of a it's a bit of a frat party and i
think it's bad enough happening inside
number 10 outside of the pandemic let
alone during it and i think ultimately
the prime minister has to bear
responsibility for that
and look when this first broke i said to
you at the very beginning of this that
boris sets the tone you know he loves to
be loved he loves to run a relaxed show
and unfortunately i think that this is
the result and i i'll give you one
example um martin reynolds who your
viewers will probably know now party
marty he's the guy that we now
understand sent the email that said oh i
think we've gotten away with it boris's
principal private secretary i know
martin he's a lovely guy he's very very
capable but you have to ask why was he
enabling all this to happen he's the
prime minister's office gatekeeper he's
not some detached civil servant this guy
was hand-picked by boris at the time
plucked from an ambassadorial job in
libya they'd worked together at the
foreign office the idea that this was
all happening in some parallel universe
seems to me nonsense and i think
overridingly what worried me yesterday
is that you know boris reiterated that
he took personal responsibility that he
was humbled and he was sorry and in a
sense you know
he absolutely is
but what worried me was that every
opportunity he seemed to minimize that
he emphasized how brief his visits to
the parties were he defended his own
actions and what was extraordinary is he
said when it came to thanking staff at a
gathering which someone was fined for
and therefore was illegal he didn't
think he'd done anything wrong and
actually he'd do it again and i think
what worries me about that is that it
makes the whole apology seem somewhat
irrelevant like he's some sort of
toddler he's been forced into an apology
he gets caught and he runs off
protesting the unfairness of it all and
where i would disagree with say chris
bryant who you had on a few minutes ago
is that i know i've known boris for a
long time he will be genuinely shocked
and sorry about the rudeness towards
cleaning and security staff so what
steve barkley says is is absolutely true
that's not his bag at all he would have
been genuinely appalled but i think
there's a problem here i think the rest
of it unlike a lot of people he doesn't
see this as the big deal that people are
making out and i think the question we
have to ask ourselves is is why he
thinks that
do you think he knew what was going on
no you're not
you know i i don't think there's
anything
deliberate here i mean i think you'd
have to be fairly blind not to notice
you know music pumping out in the in the
middle of the night or or people going
on longer or frankly
you know bottle strewn everywhere or
vomit on the walls on the other hand
he's running a country
during a pandemic and i think that's the
problem my feeling from reading the
report yesterday and you know listening
to the whistleblowers who were on the
bbc's panorama program the other night
is that downing street unlike the rest
of the country was a bubble of normality
there was no sign whatsoever that any of
the changes that were made to the rest
of the country were made inside downing
street and i think this is clearly why
the partying the sort of wine time
fridays at 4 p.m didn't raise any
eyebrows because everything else was
carrying on as normal no restrictions no
distancing in office life so when the
work day ended life carried on as normal
no one else was having leaving parties
because no one else was in a normal
working environment around the country
and honestly i cannot fathom why downing
street didn't put in best practice from
the off screens one rate corridors
essential staff only of course they're
responding to a pandemic but why did the
prime minister and his senior staff not
say you know i want the 30 most senior
people in this building in every day
everyone else works remotely and
leadership is about setting
responsibility setting the tone and i
don't think boris did in that sense and
and yesterday
what worried me was that boris seemed to
admit that a leaving party was a normal
and nice thing to do it was leadership
but in a world where everybody at that
time was cancelling weddings funerals
christenings not visiting dying
relatives not having a leaving party
seems to me a pretty basic sacrifice to
make and i think he genuinely considered
downing street to be an exception to the
rules he and others didn't do anything
wrong because they were in a very
specific very high pressure situation
but so were nhs doctors saving lives
and if they if they had partied with
people from outside number 10 they would
have known it was wrong but within the
building they were all working together
so therefore the rules weren't the same
and i think he probably genuinely
believes that and hence those who think
otherwise are political opportunists or
they're just being like massively over
the top so when it comes to resignation
why would he consider resigning when he
doesn't really think that he's done
anything fundamentally wrong
well we're out of time um eloquently put
as always great to talk to you thank you
very much thanks kate take care